[Music]
you are watching the press preview the
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with the political editor of the new
statesman stephen bush and the
telegraphs parliamentary sketch writer
madeline grant so let's see what's on
some of those front pages for you now
the financial times reports energy
companies are seeking emergency
government support to weather the crisis
meanwhile the metro says ministers are
downplaying talks of a crisis despite
holding emergency talks with suppliers
the eye has the same story noting
consumers are already facing a 139 pound
a year energy bill rise from next month
and the guardian says hospitals could
cancel operations due to a lack of co2 a
knock-on effect of the high gas prices
the telegraph leads on boris johnson's
trip to america saying he will push
president biden to lift the ban on uk
travelers to the country
the mail calls for family gps to carry
out more face-to-face appointments
amidst fears illnesses are being missed
in phone and video consultations
goodbye greasy that's on the front of
the mirror which describes footballer
jimmy grieves as a true legend
a similar headline for the star which
pays tribute to only fools and horses
star john chalice
and the yorkshire post has a warning
from the west yorkshire mayor that the
north will pay a heavy price if the
planned hs2 route to leeds is cancelled
okay well let's uh
take you to our guest now take us
through the papers stephen and madeline
welcome to you both um let's start with
the telegraph um front page and the
prime minister's
trip to new york uh the headline there
johnson to press u.s to open up for uk
visitors uh we know that he will be
speaking in new york but also we'll have
a a meeting after the the conference
with the president and looks like this
might be high on the agenda stephen
yes um now obviously as as viewers
who've tried to go to the states will
know uh at the moment essentially if
you're not a united states citizen um
you basically aren't getting in uh this
obviously has big implications for the
economy big implications for people's uh
personal lives
but um the important sort of missing
piece of the puzzle here is the thing
that the british government did last
week which is um very sensibly changing
our rules for ongoing and going travel
to essentially to move to the old
traditional system of international
vaccine passports now if you're double
vaxxed you can come into the united
kingdom unless you're in a hot spot uh
area uh a very sensible move yeah
getting rid of a lot of the slightly
pointless bureaucracy around traveling
into and out of the united kingdom but
also of course that allows boris johnson
to say in this meeting look i've done
this mature sensible thing uh could you
do us a solid by also doing this mature
sensible thing which you know isn't just
about the us uk relationship it is also
about getting the global economy um
moving again uh after the the pandemic
uh madeline do you think he he stands a
fair chance in in convincing that the
president that this is the way forward
well
i'm not sure exactly because obviously
they're on a bit of a high what with the
new pact that's been signed and
relations seemed to be after a difficult
period in which the
catastrophic chaotic withdrawal from
afghanistan seemed to reveal the extent
to which america was taking decisions
alone i think for many observers the
news that britain had come together with
america and australia to form this pact
um was was with a heartening development
but you know as stephen pointed out
these rules have been in place for a
very long time um a nonsensically long
time many would say and they have taken
a quite a indiscriminate and crude
approach to
the travel bans that have has seemed to
ignore the evidence that has seemed to
ignore the state of the country that
people are traveling from it seems to be
very much a kind of america first type
thing that goes purely on nationality so
that there has been they have taken
quite a stubborn stance so far um so you
would hope that a charm offensive would
overturn that but i think it's you know
it's it remains to be seen uh very much
and you know that as well as the travel
issue there's a whole bunch of other
things in the pm's intro that he will be
want he will want to uh be discussing
with the president trying to exact
further commitments of funding to tackle
climate change and all sorts of things
so it seems like there's quite a few
things that are kind of
in the pm's uh intra as he goes sort of
cap in hand
yes and that the the climate change also
uh the the precursor to cop 26 in
november um from downing street this
this evening we heard that the prime
minister will be saying that richer
countries have pledged to spend a
hundred billion dollars a year to help
poorer nations cut their carbon
emissions um but but so far that target
hasn't been met so uh one would think he
he's hoping to to exert a bit of
pressure over in the state stephen
yeah he will hope that but i mean as
madeline sets out it's difficult um you
know
ultimately the u.s can do what it wants
what it wants to do and it is also
i think difficult because
it's not like these rules have just
become silly in the last week um the
us's approach to the coronavirus border
has been weird for some time uh so it's
i think it's unlikely and we'll see much
change then
let's have a look at the metro uh their
headline crisis what crisis um many
assurances from ministers that that
everything is is under control but but
are we assured madeleine
i don't i don't think so um because on
the one hand we have alex sharma making
some quite bullish remarks on the andrew
miles show saying that he's quite
confident that we won't see massive
disruption that they have they're not
being complacent and so on um but
ultimately you know it is a big gamble
because if the coming winter sees power
cuts and shortages and
it's already looks certain that energy
bills are going to rise considerably uh
then the government will um have been
seen to be
very complacent indeed um and it's also
perhaps not helped by the fact that on
the same day that he's he's
they talk of their confidence so also
all of these crisis talks being reported
on about the energy companies
requesting bailouts kind of financial
crisis style bailouts of um energy
suppliers who who face annihilation um
thanks to the the rise in the wholesale
uh price of of natural gas so it seems
that they say one thing but then
underneath the surface there's an awful
lot of kind of frenetic um planning and
um and and discussions going on at the
same time so it doesn't inspire great
confidence
stephen is it is it a crisis or or
should we be as
relaxed about the situation as the the
government seemed to be at this stage
well i think the proof of the pudding as
it were is in the story then that you
know you had to to break into right
before this segment about bulb uh
seeking additional credit now the way
the british energy market works
essentially is that they gamble on the
idea that at the point they buy the
energy
it will be cheaper than when they sold
it uh to you to me to
businesses around the united kingdom and
the problem with the uh the rise in
prices is at the moment that gamble is
not coming off
um so it's hard to see unless there's
some kind of government bailout or
something unexpected happens
particularly if we if you're one of the
newer entrants in the energy market then
this isn't going to be quite a bumpy
time for you so i think it is hard to
see how uh alexander's remarks this
morning aren't going to go down as a
little bit complacent about the uh yeah
at least the immediate short-term future
of the of the british energy market
yes and uh madam following on from what
stephen was saying there the ft talking
about energy groups uh seeking emergency
support
yeah that's right um they're requesting
emergency support measures um and you
know full-scale bailouts um and they're
concerned that without more assistance
from government that if if these
companies were to go bust and then that
could fall really badly on the consumers
as well because if they're forced to
move to a different provider there's
absolutely no guarantee that they will
keep paying at the same rate and because
of the price of supplying um for many
companies they say it's not in their
financial interest even to take on new
customers um so they they want to see
further assurances from governments and
there's also been
in the last few days quite a few um
industry figures have been saying that
they would like to see the environmental
levies that
hike up the the bills forward
reconsumers for those to be relaxed or
at least suspended to help make up the
shortfall uh because a good proportion
of people's bills are are
spent paying these green levees um but
you know that would be quite difficult
to square with the government's net zero
commitments it seems as if we are
finally i think reaching a crunch point
where the the cost of actually meeting
these vast commitments that have been
made by
under the previous administration and by
politicians we're finally starting to
see the reality on the ground at this
you know pain and financial hardship for
wouldn't we consumers
and stephen one of the things the energy
companies are saying is that the energy
cap should be scrapped or at the very
least raised do you think that is a
realistic prospect that that's something
that the government might actually look
at at this stage
well it's yeah in terms of the options
available for the government you can go
for a bailout which of course has a very
big upfront cost uh to the government
itself or you can try and essentially
have a publicly sourced bailout by
lifting the amount then you're lifting
that lifting that cap
so i think you know if i were advising
rishi sunak i would be quite tempted by
the uh the energy map option but if i
were advising boris johnson i'd probably
be saying look we've got this very
painful cut to universal credit coming
in we've already got signs of inflation
which may be temporary as we aren't
about as about us unlocking but it may
not be do you really want to have um
inflation in terms of people's energy
bills on top of that as well
probably not and so you can see how the
policy and the political argument here
aren't that balanced and so um you know
who knows what to end up with but yeah
it's tempting for that reason because it
means the upfront cost doesn't sort of
make a further dent in these already
quite tight spending plans with the csr
what two weeks three weeks away
madeleine what are your thoughts on
ending the the price cap
well i mean
it's
it's a it's a difficult one because the
the price cap in itself was was a kind
of a form of interference it was it was
creating a sort of an artificial sense
of what of of what the true price was
that there was always going to be this
element of pain um when it was removed
um but i suppose that it's come at a
particularly uh fought time um where
global trends have conspired to create
to ramp up the price of wholesale gas
but as i said before i think that you
know there was inevitably going to be a
great deal of pain and i think perhaps
for for too long in fact politicians
have not been entirely transparent with
the public about what all of this was
going to cost um and you know i think
people would feel more reassured if they
could if we weren't getting such
contradictory messages from politicians
even now where you'll have alex sharma
say one thing and then at the same time
there'll be these worrying statistics
and um crisis discussions going on with
the energy industry at the same time
uh one of the lines that the eye is
running uh they're saying that britons
may be left without turkey on christmas
day because of the shortage um stephen
do you think that the public are aware
of of how close they are to this
potential crisis
um no i think partly because you know
candidly right we're sitting here
discussing this i think we're you know
we're hardwired to be optimists right do
i listen to this and think oh this might
happen i think oh no i'm sure it'll be
sorted out i think that's actually how
most people encounter most most scary
problems
and we're being paid to talk about it
and pay to read the papers right so i
think the you know most people will look
at this and kind of put out their minds
and hope that it will sort itself out
that of course is the big risk for the
government then if it isn't sorted out
people will um not you know not
unreasonably be quite upset quite scared
and quite angry
indeed stephen and madeline thank you
very much for the moment we are going to
take a break coming up
french cancel uk defense meeting that's
on the front of the guardian as the
diplomatic spat continues to stay with
us
[Music]
[Music]
i'm greg milam skye's u.s correspondent
here in los angeles
can you go away
we take you to the heart of stories that
shape our world
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm stuart ramsey and i'm sky's chief
correspondent
i think it's a procession of uh
of the taliban uh yes it is there's the
white flag
we saw snatched going in grabbing people
and putting them into trucks
you either live and recover
or you die
[Music]
okay so that's like a wall that's the
war yes
we help you understand the world with us
over the past 24 hours the soldiers have
been attacked on a number of occasions
it's really sending a clear message that
venezuela is eager for change
winding corrupts
we take you to the heart of stories that
shape our world
they were convinced the united states
would become hooked when they were right
when norma's sixth
the information on this could bring down
the entire network not just in iraq and
syria but across the world
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
it was my vision to come and protect
regulation future
[Music]
animals like lion can enter into bombas
they kill their livestocks and this
leads to human wildlife
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me this evening stephen
bush and madeline grant welcome back to
both of you let's um take a look in this
section starting off with the guardian
and this is the story of the um
meeting of uh defence ministers british
defense ministers with their french
counterparts which has been cancelled
and this is over the loss of a 48
billion pound submarine contract um take
us into this story stephen this
diplomatic spat seems to be getting uh
worse going from bad to worse
yeah right so the beginning of this
diplomatic spat
actually starts about a month ago when
the australian prime minister scott
morrison having signed this deal with
the french government to provide a new
nuclear-powered submarines said
your deal's great i love your submarines
i couldn't get enough of them you know
give me all the subs in the land
and then it turns out because it's been
announced this week then all that time
he's been negotiating a different deal
uh to provide uh military hardware
intelligence sharing with
the united states and the united kingdom
this new uh so-called orcas i think
that's how we've all decided in
westminster to
pronounce it yes deal between australia
the uk and the united states this of
course has uh caused a great deal of
upset uh for france because obviously
defense contracts are a huge part of
trade they're one of the few very
tangible things and you can point to
your voters and you get out of these
defenses france has suspended their
ambassadors in uh australia and the
united states and moved out of this
meeting um uh with us here at home the
the french are saying that they've been
stabbed in in the back and have said so
in no uncertain terms madeleine can you
understand that sentiment
yes there's been i mean they say that
they were barely informed about the
arrival of of the new pacs i still think
that the language that they've used is
is pretty extraordinary that's
far fruitier than you tend to hear from
uh diplomats and um
suave politicians um even the french who
do have a tendency to throw a bit of a
wobbler in these situations um but
there's been
that there's been um
they've recalled diplomats from
australia and america and they've
taunted britain and claimed that britain
is well is now irrelevant even though it
was they who were excluded or say they
were excluded um
and you know i think it will take
serious time and political leadership to
try to to fix the frosty relationship
because the kind of outbursts that that
we've heard over the last few days are i
would say quite extraordinary and not
what you would usually um hear in
politics um but at the same time and
it's not perhaps not that surprising
because in some ways
uh france and indeed the eu itself have
been quite out of step with with with
america on things like um invest in
investment investing in china
and things like the nordstrom project
with russia um and even um excluding
britain from the galileo satellite
project that there is a sense and i
don't think it's unfounded that they
have been out of step by the with the
aims of nato and and of america
let's move on to the male stephen and
this story about the the consequences
the very serious consequences of many of
us not having face-to-face contact with
our gps and the various illnesses that
have been missed
yeah this is the the big thing right is
that during a pandemic of course uh many
gp not all but many gp surgeries move to
no face-to-face appointments at all uh
if you're lucky like i am your my local
practice has moved back to to
face-to-face and actually i think the
new system works around here a lot than
the old lots of places on um this
obviously creates lots of problems for
patients but of course the kind of
double-sided story here is one of the
roles of gps in our system is actually
act as medical gatekeeper and one of the
ways they're doing it after the pandemic
is by putting another barrier in front
of them people actually having to see
them uh so yeah i think this is a big
important story but it is one which has
uh you know will cause you know further
costs and you get more of that money and
we've already seen taxes going up to
fund the nhs well i imagine we'll see
more headlines like that uh in the you
know months and years ahead
just finally madeline uh the tributes
have been coming into to jimmy greaves
and the mirror um has a
lovely picture of him actually just uh
take us into this
yes they do and um i don't want to
embarrass myself by um talking too much
about football especially because
stephen is a real expert um
but one thing i've been really struck by
by reading all the tributes um you know
it was the sense that um
the time in which jimmy grieves was
playing in the 60s i think he was chosen
for the uh world cup team but then had
to pull out shortly before because of
injury so it's that kind of era it's
just the way that uh the extent to which
football has changed and how it's gone
from being this far more kind of local
and sort of civilian approach to the
biomorphic thing that we see now so um
jimmy grieves had a hundred grand record
transfer from ac milan to spurs in 1961.
we have run out of time thank you so
much thank you both madeline and stephen